foreign
video from Crimea overnight purporting
to show the moment the Kirch Bridge came
under attack again
[Music]
on the bridge cars quickly backed up
initially Russia said an emergency
situation had closed it to traffic
authorities then said a couple had been
killed in their car their 14 year old
daughter wounded Russian media said
there were tourists heading towards
Crimea
on the night of July 16
as a result of the terrorist act
committed by the Ukrainian special
services one of the sections of the
Crimean Bridge was damaged two civilians
were killed a man and a woman who were
driving a car their daughter was injured
she is receiving medical assistance
Russian investigators said two Ukrainian
Seaborn drones were responsible
Ukrainian media quoted unnamed officials
in Kiev saying it was a joint operation
involving the intelligence service and
the Navy it's the second time in nine
months that a section of the bridge has
been severely damaged in October last
year the road bridge was struck by a
major explosion that also set fire to a
train on The Rail Link Russia blamed a
Ukrainian truck-born bomb
The Bridge completed in 2018 four years
after Russia's annexation of the Crimean
Peninsula is a vital logistical link as
well as civilian traffic it supplies the
Black Sea Fleet and Russian troops in
occupied Southern Ukraine once again
it's closed at least to road traffic
a key advisor to Ukraine's president
zielinski tweeted on Monday that illegal
constructions used to deliver Russian
instruments of mass murder were
short-lived Ukraine's Security Service
added that the bridge had gone to sleep
again Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera